we have no confidence that
perpetrators are being brought to
Justice we've talked to a handful of
police officers nearby in this incident
and the previous incident and they said
that
they sort of shrugged their shoulders he
jokes that she got through 70 years of
her life without a gun put in her face
that was Diana digiacomo's son-in-law
describing what you're seeing on your
screen right now
in broad daylight in Chicago's Tony
Lincoln Park neighborhood she was robbed
at gunpoint Diana said the thug demanded
her purse or he'd shoot her her dog uh
he snatched her purse and as you can see
it fled down an alley the Giacomo says
that she saw the man with his hand in
her bag before he threw it to the ground
it wasn't until later she realized that
her car key was stolen she's also been
carjacked joining me now is that woman
in the horrible video Diana the Giacomo
Diana I have a lot of friends who live
in Lincoln Park
it's a beautiful neighborhood historic
neighborhood
what are Chicago's political leaders
saying tonight given what's happening
with crime obviously what happened to
you is being repeated all too often
it is and Laura thank you first of all
thank you for having me on thank you for
all the great reporting that you do
um I I'm the the only reason that I am
here to talk to you about this is
because
if people don't show up and vote to
change
the leadership in Chicago this is only
going to continue to get worse
um I'm 70 years old I've been my entire
life without ever having been mugged and
I take my dog out for two seconds to
go on a lawn and
this is what happens in the middle of
the day in Chicago in in Lincoln Park
which is a beautiful neighborhood
beautiful homes
um people have have you know just
invested a lot of money in their houses
and they pay a lot of tax money to live
there and
and this is what's happening in the
middle of the day it's just not
acceptable well Diana there's a lot of
folks that I know in the area they're
you know pretty liberal to say the least
I mean it's a very liberal politically
very liberal area
so they keep voting they keep voting for
these folks so that I mean at some point
it's the definition of insanity is it
not you're voting for Lori Lightfoot or
other members of the uh the city council
and yes there are no changes the poor
police are are outmanned and outgunned
we we had a chance to get rid of our uh
State's Attorney Kim Fox
Jesse from All That Walk and
didn't didn't get her out of office and
I I don't want to be naming names but I
I have basically
um just in September changed my
residence to my house in Lake Geneva
because my vote doesn't count in
Illinois that's how I feel yeah so Diana
yeah you're like others uh and you have
the wherewithal to the mains I should
say to to leave because you have at home
in in Wisconsin but a lot of people
don't they're stuck there especially the
underprivileged people this has to
change thank you for speaking out and uh
this video is just another another
example of why things need to be
different in uh Urban America hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else